[Music]
foreign
before we get started I really want to
say that this is going to be very long
very nerdy and if you pick up any of
these books I promised you will never be
the same person again now that the
pleasantries are out of the way let's
just get straight into the top 13 books
that I implore you to read in 2023 let's
get started the very first book is on
tethered soul and if you are already
tempted to click off this video I don't
blame you because the first time I heard
this title I thought it was probably
some Midwestern Bromance and I got
cowboy and horses Vibes and it's really
not that it's actually a philosophy book
and an amazing one I would call this
book a cure for Stress neuroticism and
Anxiety so if any of these resonated
with you firstly hi and to pick up this
book it genuinely will change your life
it provided me with perspectives that I
had never had before and I don't know
how to explain this but it felt as
though it was kind of perfect for me as
in a lot of these mindsets resonate with
Buddhism and with Alan Watts with a lot
of things that I'd been slowly accruing
for the last 10 years of my life but
they were verbalized perfectly in this
book it has the best balance when it
comes to me in terms of tough love and
soft love and in terms of morality and
lack of morality and questioning and not
questioning and acceptance and
Punishment and just everything about it
just felt the perfect Elizabeth balance
so if you find that our brains kind of
work the same it might also help you a
lot this book was a genuine Escape for
me I've read it almost once a week for
this whole year and it kind of provided
grounding at almost it became a coping
mechanism or a safety net that I would
return to whenever my anxiety levels
would rise or I would find myself
re-spiring because I do think the things
that are mentioned in the book are
absolutely amazing but they are so
contrary to how I Am Naturally and I
tend to be I think a bit more of a
tightly bound up and anxious person as
the book also says itself the one who
notices is already free and even though
I cannot completely transform myself
overnight or or as I finish this book
into this calm collected and kind of
meditative and accepting person I think
the path of recognizing that I am
perhaps doing things in a way that makes
me sadder or more anxious or more
neurotic is freedom within itself I
can't do the book full Justice in a few
seconds but I just want to mention that
it's kind of centered around the view
that we are separate to what we are
thinking feeling and experiencing and
this is also what one of my favorite
poets John O'Donoghue says when he
mentions there's always a part of you
that has never been hurt and I think
this is what this book does it kind of
expands in that space which is safe and
happy and pleasant and calm and relaxed
and kind of lets it take over in a way
and helps you create systems and ways of
perceiving things and viewing the world
that makes you get closer and closer I
think to that calm acceptance and that
separation from all the negative
feelings that one might experience in
their life as Jeanette winterson said to
be ill adjusted to a deranged world is
not a breakdown and therefore I'm really
happy when I find books like this which
make the act of living life and taking
upon challenges just a bit easier and
help me rebalance myself and understand
myself a bit better and perceive the
world differently this book does what
John O'Donoghue says that we should be
focusing more on and I agree with which
is not the view of who I should be or
what I should be but how I should be and
I think it's very easy to take on
challenges and to take on specific goals
but to not focus in the meantime on how
we are and how we experience things and
I think this is what this book gives us
the ability to take upon challenges and
to do what we're currently doing or try
to experience more while at the same
time trying to be a bit more humble
centered calm less anxious and less
tightly wound up which is a slight
projection of course so if your brain
works anything like mine I think this
book if you can get over the cringe of
the title is an absolute must and I
would genuinely genuinely recommend it
as consistent reading in the background
on top of everything else the second
book I'm going to recommend is my
favorite fictional book of the year
which is Project Hail Mary which is very
surprisingly I fell in love with I've
given that is a Sci-Fi book and I was
never into the Sci-Fi genre I never
properly got into Star Wars as a child
and then I thought that [ __ ] has sailed
I'm too old for this I don't think I'm
going to be into this weird stuff but
it's actually brilliant I think it's
perfect for me and I had never realized
this book was a recommendation for my
YouTube comments so thank you so much to
the person who did that because changed
my life so so good the reason that I
realized that sci-fi is actually
incredible is that the core thing on
which sci-fi is woven is not actually
weird stories and aliens and kind of end
of the world things that I thought but I
mean it is that but the core of it I
think is a deep deep desire to
understand humanity and there's so much
philosophy and psychology in it as we
put people in these extreme decisions of
end of the world kids are dying
everyone's burning world is going down
um there's that side of seeing human
beings at the extreme and what then lies
underneath in our core once the daily
interests and the daily issues and the
daily problems and stresses Stripped
Away but on the other level it's kind of
a consistent thought experiment I love
the four experiments of what would
aliens think if they saw us doing
something because I love doing that so I
think sci-fi kind of collected this and
captured this really really well the way
that I picture it is that the
independent variable in this book is how
much emotion we are putting into it and
how much we are assuming we know about
people and as these varies there are
levels when we take away all of our
emotion and we take away all of our our
assumptions for Humanity and we're left
with this dependent variable of what it
means to be human and what's the reality
behind that in this book we question
things such as morality what is good
what is bad what is love what is death
and even question behaviors like why do
we take turns is that a universal thing
why do these even make sense and in
doing so very interestingly why having
this almost dispassionate detached
stressed curious analysis of humanity
for some reason I ended up the book
feeling more emotional and human and
pathetic than ever it was such a
beautiful journey into what it means to
be a person and to be alive and I would
genuinely generally recommend it so much
and then on top of that you have the
benefit of having a Sprinkle of Science
and physics and especially astrophysics
which is my favorite which kind of keeps
your interests in the book really really
high so this was absolutely beautiful I
will admit I almost cried at one point
that I don't want to spoil but if you
are into fiction at all and if
especially you have not read sci-fi and
you're like me and you think you
wouldn't like it try this try this it's
so good so so so so good incredible so
yeah the next book is creativity the
psychology of Discovery and invention
which is based on the idea that in
general humans seem to have gone from a
state of thinking that the gods had
created us to thinking that we have
actually created the gods and we've
taken upon ourselves this title of
creator with not exactly the full
responsibility or Insight or curiosity
or passion to understand or do it well
and therefore it's kind of a very
interesting exploration into work and
productivity and creativity and
Discovery in general this book is
written by me hey samihai which if
you're like me and you've read a lot
about work and organization and flow you
know this name comes up again and again
he is one of the biggest scientific
researchers and one of the biggest names
in the literature of flow and
productivity and so his name was coming
up again and again in so many different
books so I had to go to his own written
book which is actually quite old at this
stage but it's so insightful and
interesting as a lot of people I think
in my audience are kind of scientific
and would potentially not identify with
being creative which we very often
associate with fluffy things like dance
and music and painting and drawing and
scribbling and all that stuff I've
divided the benefits of this book into
two groups the cynical so the science
productivity-ish person and then also
the Romantic so the creative person so
when it comes to the cynic I would read
this book because it really really
focuses on the positive aspects of
creativity and how this can can be
applied to any sort of task that you do
I'm talking about things like flow about
passion in your subject about finding
new and alternative ways of solving
problems of being obsessed with the
thing that you are doing of maintaining
your passion and curiosity about work
that doesn't need to be creative in the
long term so all of these can be taken
by people like Michelangelo or Einstein
or people who are fully obsessed with
their subjects achieve things to a very
high level but we're also very very
creative in the solutions and the things
that they found and did and on the other
hand you have the romantic and this is
the person I identify a lot with a
romantic this is the person who just
kind of loves art but potentially
doesn't see themselves as creative and
she wants to have a bit more newness and
to experiment with things in their life
as chick sent me highs as chick sent me
high as checks
at me high
says the world is actually our business
and this basically means that everything
is ours to explore we don't need to
label ourselves as a mathematician or
physician or philosopher or a painter or
a podcaster in order to do these things
but we can just have genuine curiosity
and Dabble with them and as someone who
always gets intimidated about talking
about subjects that I'm not an expert in
I think this advice is absolutely
beautiful and the benefit of this is the
cross-pollination and therefore the
creativity that you can have in your
main subjects or topics that you are
working in beyond the specific
productivity advice to Sammy Hai also
recommends that we keep exploring what
it means to be different to who we are
and this open-mindedness this lack of
gatekeeping for so many beautiful
aspects of human nature is absolutely
incredible he also really convinced me
to look more into literature and the
Arts because unlike other more
scientifically based subjects these are
things where over a lifetime I can
improve thousands and thousands and
times over as for example a poet or as a
painter or as a singer or as a musician
and I would still have thousands of
thousands of times of improvement space
because these are kind of endless
subjects to explore and therefore they
are really really interesting for all of
us to have some sort of endless source
of creativity in our life to keep us
going and to keep improving and next is
the book Love by Jeanette winterson and
I've been looking everywhere for it
because I have a physical copy but I
think I've given it to someone to read
um and so I bought Liberty by Virginia
Woolf which is another vintage Mini
because I just want to show you the size
of this book to convince you to please
please get it because they're quite
small they have really big tags and they
are so interesting I love president is a
collection of her thoughts and her other
pieces of writing on love and it is
undescribable I can't I don't have words
for how beautiful impactful and
emotional this writing is it's really
really short but I think that this woman
is someone who has been just
so fortunate for the rest of us to exist
in the sense of how insightful she is
how strongly and deeply she experiences
things and tests things out but also how
much she then reflects on them and her
gift and talent and work into writing
and expressing things is not there's a
word for it I think she does so well
something that is called wait let me let
me find the specific term there's
something in Psychiatry called the
unknown thought which is basically
things that you don't have words for you
don't even know that you're experiencing
but are definitely there and what people
like her do is kind of make me realize
all of that and she just pulls back the
curtain on so much feelings that I had
never processed or never understood and
you feel so connected to someone through
things that are admittedly very very
painful and to the extent that we
potentially have never shared with
anyone or have been even too embarrassed
to admit to ourselves when it comes to
the complexities of relationships and
love she explores not only romantic love
but she explores also parent and child
love and I just can't express how
beautiful this this little and emotional
and how much content and value there is
in this tiny tiny book I'm going to read
one very little um kind of extract
format just to give you an idea of the
way that she writes and the parallels
that she draws
um so she said this is super short but
she says I should have so this is about
my mother talking about her son I should
have named him after a stagnant Pond and
then I could have kept him but I named
him after a river and in the flood tide
He Slipped Away So it's talking about
the realization of her mother that a
child would leave and this parallel
between being a pond or a river just a
beautiful she incredibly talented would
definitely recommend so cathartic so
beautiful so poetic absolutely
incredible 100 out of 10 would recommend
this book next I actually do have a
physical copy of this is a Vindication
on the rights of women by Mary
Wollstonecraft now this is the OG
feminist kind of book so it's first very
feminism It Was Written in the 1700s so
I think it's
1792 I believe
1792 was when it was first published and
this is incredible a must read now I
will admit I did not know a lot about
feminism and I've kind of obviously knew
the basics of it but I think in very
recent years it has taken some
interesting twists and turns which a lot
of which I completely disagree with and
I therefore kind of I think I just got
confused I guess with the situation and
everything that's unfolding in the space
and therefore I thought actually let me
clear my thoughts and go back to the
original so this is where feminism
started this is the issues that were
being faced at the time and how they
were expressed and how they were
verbalized and what was identified and
what the solutions were proposed at the
time so this is where it started so I
thought I
I don't know what to do right now I'll
just go back to the structure this is
why I picked up this book it is so good
this version of it is super cool because
it's quite like nice and small so I can
just fit it in my bag and I've been
reading it when I've had to travel
um long Journeys to and back from
hospital so it's been a great read for
um for that reason this book is of
course incredible given the time that it
was written and it is a wonderful source
of understanding and grounding on what
can be very very complex topics I'm
going to mention one thing that I love
from her perspective
um where she says that Independence is
the basis of every virtue which
basically states that if one is forced
to behave in a certain way they are not
a virtuous person because it's not
coming inherently so if someone has no
other option other than to be virtuous
they are not technically virtuous but
it's absolutely beautiful and there's
obviously a lot of translations into not
necessarily just the history and the
politics of the issue but also
understanding more about one's own life
and one's own understanding even
generalizing to self-respect and to the
way that we perceive ourselves and how
we live our lives
um some small thing that I really like
about this is
um that Mary herself there's a bit in
the a book that talks about her personal
history and I found it very reassuring
and this might be super random but the
fact that when it came to her personal
life of course she was a very
forward-thinking
independent incredible woman when it
came to her personal life she actually
faced a lot of
issues in her personal relationships
with her partner and with her husband
she kind of I guess was not as feminist
as she potentially would have liked or
it kind of went it kind of contradicted
her her thoughts and I found this of
course to be quite painful because she
did go through a lot of emotional pain
I'm sure in her relationships but also
found it to be quite reassuring in that
one can have political views and
thoughts and beliefs that are necessary
not congruent with their behavior
because especially when it comes to
emotional matters or matters of the
heart
um one can still behave in ways that are
regrettable and not exactly the ideal of
what they would like themselves to
believe so I found that to be very very
reassuring that even a woman like her um
of course not ideal went through a lot
of relationship struggles but otherwise
Incredible Book really really good I'd
get back to the OG if you're also like
me completely baffled as to where this
movement and Direction has gone at the
moment the next book I want to recommend
is organized chaos which is actually my
book um I wrote a book this year it was
super impulsive and it was kind of a
moment where I snapped and thought no I
need to do this and I just felt very
very strongly about a particular concept
when it came to work and organizing
oneself and the way that one views
myself and makes
um things happen and so I just sat down
and wrote this book and I'm very very
happy with it I think only months and
months later now with all the feedback
and all the emails I'm comfortable
enough to actually say
it did quite well and I back it and it
was a really really good and
life-changing experience for me myself
making it but also for I guess for
according to what I've been told by also
other people who have gotten this book I
don't want to linger on this book too
much and unfairly but I just want to say
that organized chaos is about the
chaotic impatient kind of distractible
can't get things done sort of person who
has tried and failed so much like me
with kind of General work advice and
time blocking and sit down and just just
do it and habits and things like that
and it's an alternative to making these
things happen because I think trying and
failing and feeling terrible my whole
life to stick to the mainstream advice
and then going the complete opposite
direction and now for example I am a
full-time medical student and I run this
channel go TV by myself and all of these
things and managed to have a personal
life and all this stuff using uh tips
that are more chaotically organized
rather than mainstream and habit focused
is just the way that I managed to live
what can be consider a more balanced and
a happier life so that's what the book
is about if you're anything like me
um maybe it might be also helpful for
you but I'm going to move swiftly on now
next book recommendation is attachment
in Psychotherapy and this is 10 out of
10. it is so good please please please
make the time to read books like this so
this was prompted by a series of other
books that I read so basically
um you've probably heard of attached
attached is great it's a book about your
attachment style in romantic
relationships whether you are sequoia or
you are avoidant or you are preoccupied
and it's really really helpful in
identifying what sort of approach you
have to interpersonal relationships and
how then that might dictate the kind of
people you are attracted to or the sorts
of issues or progression of
relationships and it's really really
great but attached is a pop psychology
book still it's still just like an
expansion and interpretation of what's
actually very well established science
where I thought that this might help me
is more with the book that I'm
recommending which is attachment in
Psychotherapy which is actually a book
for therapists I know this is high level
but let me let me make my argument here
I really think that attachment Styles
extend a lot farther than our romantic
relationships but they form the basis of
who we think we are and how we interpret
things are happening in the world and
especially things that are happening
with us there's attachment that we have
to friends to family members to people
at work to people in romantic
relationships to our own children and
especially when it comes to
intergenerational trauma and kind of the
effects that we had for the maladaptive
ways perhaps that we were raised can
very easily and there's a lot of
evidence to show that unless these are
addressed these are things that we are
then giving on to our children and they
are not ideal I find that I love my
distress a lot of my anxieties my
insecurities my issues when it comes to
my life stem at the core from a problem
with attachment and so this has been
something that I have been tackling head
on this year and it's honestly one of
the most difficult interesting amazing
and life-changing things one can do to
their psychology and their experience of
Life honestly the most important thing
like screen productivity screw my book
pick this up because it's so so
incredible so this book is actually
targeted towards um therapists as I
mentioned but the explanations are
incredible the understanding is so in
depth it is brilliant and especially if
you are someone who has been wanting to
go to therapy for a while but for
whatever reason is unable to this might
perhaps be a more affordable solution or
a start not a replacement for but a step
towards this thing in the end of the day
if you find that you perhaps a react to
things sometimes or are unhappy by the
way
things unfold in your life I would pick
up this book and see if anything in it
resonates with you or makes sense to you
because it might just change everything
would a hundred million out of 10
recommend the next book is reaching down
the rabbit hole and this is my first
medical book actually that I'm
recommending this is a mainstream
medical book because it's equally good I
think for pre-medics or for the general
population as it is for medical students
I'm not going to speak for doctors I'm
not one yet so let's pause that there
but I read it before I even went to
medical school and I reread it last year
reaching down the rabbit hole is a
collection of different stories from
people who have had very rare and unique
trauma or
um medical conditions or impairment to
their brain so these are clinical
conditions that are so so so
interesting to see and obviously that
had huge consequences on both the
families and also the interactions
between doctors and so looking into this
I think one of course makes one very
very grateful for their own existence
and whatever Health that we do have
ourselves but also it kind of helps us
peek into what life can look like
otherwise and what it may look for so
some people and also I think as always
it kind of increases your empathy and
increases your uh love for taking care
of people and in my instance my love for
medicine it's great to read if you are a
medic especially and if you're not it
kind of gives you these really
interesting stories some easy and fun
way to learn medical terms and to have a
peek into what health looks like and
what interactions between doctors and
patients look like so reaching down the
rabbit hole is really really cool and if
you have some kind of morbid fascination
with things like maybe true crime or
maybe issues like that this is a
interesting kind of dark but empathetic
view into what it means to be human when
there is lack of health and how they try
to manage and understand it especially
when it is very very unique different
and unknown so brilliant book the next
book I'm going to recommend is a decent
life from morality for the rest of us
and this is a lazy guide To Living a
modern moral life so basically if you
are the sort of person who is kind of
interested in philosophy but very
quickly kind of shuts it off when it
gets a bit much and when you feel that
it's quite difficult to actually be
completely moral today and there are so
much that being is being asked of us in
terms of should we kind of not be flying
or how much should you recycle or do you
be a vegan do you have to be a vegan and
what is our kind of effect on the and
impact on the environment or on
homelessness and there's so many issues
to care about that it feels very very
easy to just and I admit I've done this
after myself to just go you know what
I'm just gonna turn it off because I
don't know what to do so if you've
caught yourself in that position once or
twice I think this is a really good book
to read because it's very palatable
reasonable and it's very well written
it's kind of a lazy guide to being moral
today it's based on the view of decency
so even though it touches on things like
deontology or virtual effects and
different moral theories that are
classical it then lands on something
which is decency basically the view that
you should treat other people as though
they are also people with needs and that
sounds really simple and it kind of it's
but it's surprising as to how many
solutions this has in terms of both kind
of individual one-on-one interactions
but also kind of thinking about policies
and extending things beyond the
individual onto the group so it's an
absolutely beautiful re as the book says
there's no limit to what morality can
ask of us but the aim should not be that
one maximizes our benevolence in every
instance but rather that one attempts to
find ways in which one might be
benevolent so with this aim in mind this
is a great philosophy book if you are
into that stuff the next book is one
that I'm going to be honest I wasn't
sure whether or how to properly include
or mention but in reality it's a book
that has greatly changed my perspective
and I've really really sound important
this year so I thought I would mention
it's racism without cysts and this is a
book that I'm definitely not the best
person to speak of but I'll just mention
the things that stood out to me the most
provided an education and a painful to
read perspective that I did not have
access to in the past and it also
provided a view that I found very very
helpful and very interesting in the
sense that the argument of the book is
that it's not helpful to kind of label
people as being something because then
they might feel that well I'm not a bad
person I'm not that thing rather and it
kind of shut this off and then there is
no discussion to be had or no changes to
be made one of my favorite psychologists
and he's not related to the book is Dr
Kurt conda and he says something which I
truly believe which is that that it is
impossible for people to be born in and
raised in a system which is directed in
a certain way and to not be impacted by
this system and this is something to
constantly keep in mind it talks about
prejudice and discrimination especially
in the context of the group or in
structural based systems rather than
purely living responsibility on the
individual this is one of the books on
the list that even though I'm not
American or have ever been in America
yet
um I think would be a great way to read
and a very very important set of
learning points is definitely a book
that I will be returning to again just
because of how much empathy insight
understanding and information it lends
to the reader and so I would greatly
greatly recommend it next is Stephen
Hawking's the great design I feel like
every year there's a Stephen Hawking
book that just is so great I feel as
though I don't have a lot to do with
astrophysics or physics anymore in my
life and it used to be my favorite
subject in school so I do have a very
soft spot for it but also I think
there's just something so philosophical
and a different approach to philosophy
that I find in physics in that it kind
of gives answers and very very
interesting answers that are very often
quite intellectually challenging when it
comes to understanding them but also
just so beautiful and such an escape to
read and to learn and I feel that there
is nothing more interesting than
actually learning about the space that
we occupy and where we are in the
universe and in the world and what we
know about how things have potentially
come to be and just how much more
insightful grateful and interested we
can be around things that surround us
due to this so as a nihilistic physics
and philosophy nerd it's a 10 out of 10
for me my 13th and last book is
stillborn which is also another
fictional book now this is one that I'm
not going to focus on for too long
because I have a whole long video with
my summary and thoughts on it basically
it's a very very emotional book around
childbirth and loss and relationships
and interactions and there's just so
much to be learned from it the reason
that I'm going to focus on this less
than the others is that in 2023 I've
kind of decided to create a little book
club with summary of very casual videos
where I just sit down and rant about my
favorite Parts a summary of my learning
points in the books that I read and
because this rambly long informational
content does not lend itself too well to
YouTube and I don't want to completely
trash the algorithm on this channel I am
uploading them onto an algorithmic and
AD free platform which is nebula is a
platform created by educational
YouTubers and creators in general where
there's no ads there's no distractions
there's no algorithm so you go to to
watch what you want to watch and then
you can just leave and this is the
perfect space for me to upload these
videos this the summary of stillborn is
already up and I'm currently working on
summaries of some of the books that I've
mentioned today and hopefully a lot more
books that I'll be reading in the new
year so if you are interested on my
takes on books or kind of want a
shortcut to getting some information or
want to compare notes with what
resonated with us there'll be a link in
my description which will give you
access to nebula the best way to get
nebula is to sign up for curiosity
stream which is a wonderful streaming
platform for documentaries as I
mentioned if you're also nerdy into
science things there's a lot of Science
and physics and universe documentaries
there to watch which provide a lot more
insight than I can probably give in this
video or in a different way with a lot
of amazing I feel like the visuals and
the sound effects and universe
documentaries or Nature Documentaries in
general just provide a sort of blessing
for the eyes that I can get from my bed
and my bedroom in London which I
otherwise would be quite more
logistically messy to have access to now
I very good honestly promote curiosity
stream and nebula because the price for
both of these for a whole year is
literally the price of a takeaway but
it's a very reasonable package that adds
so much to my learning experience that I
would genuinely very much recommend it
but otherwise there'll be a link in my
description for the discount for
curiosity stream at nebula and also I'll
probably link all of the books that I
mentioned if that is helpful otherwise
if you mentioned to the end of this
video
you are definitely a nerd
congratulations and thank you so much
for watching I would love actually book
recommendations because projectile Mary
other books of the sort have been the
most incredible changed my life so
please please leave them below if you
resonated with us and especially if you
made it so far please just let me know
what your favorite book is this is not a
comment for the algorithm this is a I
genuinely want to know but um otherwise
thank you so much for making it so far I
hope you have a wonderful rest of your
day be count yourself and others and
don't believe everything you think
bye